hello to you mr lynch thank you for
joining us what an absolute mess
well it's a mess created by grant chaps
and government policy now we could get a
solution to this dispute grant chaps can
come to the table if he wants i'm not
particularly bothered but if he wants to
come to the table he'd be welcome as
long as he comes in a framework of
goodwill what he needs to do really is
allow the management of the train
operating companies and network rail the
license to get on with negotiating at
the minute he's dictating what they say
he's dictating what they can spend and
he's dictating that they must make
unreasonable changes in our industry
which includes for instance closing
every ticket office in britain it
includes last night's statutory
notification of compulsory redundancies
2 900
on track maintenance and it includes a
pay policy that's making people all
across britain poorer some of our
members have not had a pay rise for the
third anniversary now we can resolve
that if we've got a proper negotiating
framework but the fact is that grant
chaps rishi sunak and boris johnson are
dictating the terms of this dispute now
they can either facilitate a settlement
or they can block one at the moment
they're blocking one they're telling
lies constantly they've just told
another lie
that i've heard on your program that
we've refused to negotiate i have met
every single transport minister that's
relevant to my industries the rail
minister the bus minister the maritime
minister about issues we will meet with
government ministers any time not at
night or day as long as they come to the
table in a constructive approach
okay but you say that and you say that
grant shaps would be welcome at the
table but you're also quoted as saying
um that you wouldn't be seen dead
negotiating with the tory government so
which one is it
well i should that's just nonsense
i don't know where you got that from uh
whether you've seen me say that that's
just been made up by the tory press
office and it's being regurgitated by
various media outlets
i meet with them all of the time i've
met grant chaps i've met all that met
all of those ministers we will talk to
anyone that's got a constructive input
into the dispute or has got influence
over a settlement
why do you think grant chaps would tell
us on sky that he said that you said
that he said that you would have been
seen dead meeting with a tory government
why would he say that if you hadn't said
it
i have no idea you'd have to ask him you
might want to ask grant scheps why he's
used pseudonyms in the past to cover up
his identity i don't know what's
motivating him oh come on come on come
on i do know but i do know that they
have a strange relationship with the
truth including in parliament and on the
record and on the media
okay talk to me about what your message
is uh to the traveling public today some
who are children who will be missing
their exams could well have an impact on
their future some of them who need to
get back to work having two years of
covid and some people who could be going
to hospital appointments potentially
having surgery won't be able to do that
and could die as a result of these
strikes
well i think it'd be dramatic that
railway workers that make uh
hospitalizations die we have to give
statutory notice
of two weeks before we take industrial
action preparations can be made we've
taken four weeks since the ballot
mandate was returned and we've been
available to negotiate a settlement all
through that time as we are today and as
we were up till half seven eight o'clock
last night my message to the traveling
public is that we're very sorry for the
disruption that's been caused we don't
want to do that we want to get a
settlement to this dispute but like
everyone else many members of the
traveling public are suffering from the
austerity imposed by the government both
in the private sector and the public
sector uh profits are rampant uh
dividends are up shares are up the only
people that aren't making any money at
the moment are working people around
britain who are struggling they're
struggling in full-time work taking
state benefits and some of them are
having to use food banks we need to get
a settlement to that and the british
worker needs a pay rise they need job
security decent conditions and a square
deal in general if we can get that we
won't have to have the disruption in the
british economy that we've got now which
may develop across the summer
what would be your
advice
to other unions who are
potentially
considering ballot actions balloting for
strike action uh as well would you
support them in that
my advice to the unions is to campaign
on the issues and ultimately if the
government and the employers do not
change their direction
i believe that more ballots of strike
action are inevitable and more action is
inevitable and what i would say to trade
union leaders and trade union activists
is we need to coordinate and synchronize
our campaigning so that we can rebalance
the inequalities in our society i think
i'm knocking an open door on that
because the trade union leaders across
the tuc and across britain are telling
me that they want to join this campaign
we had a massive rally on saturday
on these issues working people are
crying out for leadership and direction
the labour party can contribute to that
but it's going to be the trade unions
that make the difference in this uh
equation at the moment
what do you mean by synchronizing
well we need to coordinate the action so
we need mass rallies we need people on
the streets we need protests in every
town uh and city and britain and if we
have to have industrial action we should
coordinate that industrial action so it
has the most effect possible
um we heard from david blunkett a labor
politician previously as you know
previously in the cabinet he said
you your union are taking us back to the
1970s
well he's talking nonsense he's out of
touch and he doesn't know what he's
talking about i started working in the
1970s are you talking about coordination
by
yeah but you're talking about
coordinating strike action with a number
of unions bringing the country to a halt
i'm talking about coordinating strike
action so that we get effective
campaigning so that british workers can
get a square deal off corporate britain
who are raking in the profits
the problem with inflation in this
country is people profiteering so if we
can get a deal with all of these
companies we won't have to have strike
action it's because we've been too
passive over the last decade or so that
workers have found themselves exploited
it's because of the lack of action and a
lack of coordination that's why british
workers are suffering it's why companies
can take advantage it's why we've got
fire and rehire right across this
economy we've got outsourcing and
precarious work so it's obvious that we
need coordinated because we need to
rebalance society
yeah but mr lynch the whole point of
coordinated action would be
i'm guessing to bring the country to all
otherwise why would you do it
no
no the point of coordinated action is to
get an effective negotiating uh position
at the table with the employers you know
i don't know what is your suggestion are
you saying that workers should passively
accept the reduction in wages the
stripping out of terms and conditions
extended hours and precarious employment
if we want a stable society where people
can guarantee their jobs where they can
look to progress themselves uh in our
society then we need strong trade unions
it seems to me that all the all the
media want to do is spout tory lines
everything that the trade unions do is
destructive it's be we've got the five
day week we've got public holidays we've
got holiday agreements we've got
pensions we've got women's rights we've
got
equalities laws all because of what the
trade unions do and have done through
our history we have been the most
progressive and democratic force in this
society and we can intend to continue to
do that
okay mr lynch i would also hope that
you'll be able to have a robust
discussion without name calling but
there we are tell me how much you're
asking for as a union what pay rise do
you want
some stations
well i'll negotiate that with employers
you know the figures the
the network rail figure at the time it
should have been settled was 7.1
i'm telling you if you let me finish
the network rail figure in december
should have been 7.1 and the train
operating companies between 7 and 8.
we'll negotiate on that there's lots of
ways to put value into a package and
we'll deal with the employers on that
basis
what would you accept
well i'm not going to discuss that with
you i'll discuss that with the people at
the negotiating table i don't i don't
negotiate on the street with a media
presenter because you you're not the
person negotiating with me so i'll deal
with the employers well negotiations are
not going very well are they and i think
the british public wants to know what's
going on so i'm asking you what the
union would accept
well i'm not going to deal with that
with you i will deal with the employers
we negotiate with them it's not very
respectful to the employers if we're
trying to put together a package that's
not just about money it's about the
conditions that our members serve under
and it's about their futures and it's
about the redundancies that we're faced
with in this industry that'll all form
part of a package and a negotiated
settlement so i'll deal with them on
that and i won't attempt to negotiate
standing on the pavement at houston
well i would have thought you'd be happy
to negotiate anywhere as long as you
managed to sort this out for your
members how much have you been offered
well
you know what we've been offered if you
read the press releases we've been
offered two percent
uh by all of the companies and there's a
further one percent available if we
accept all of the conditions including
the redundancies
and the stripping back of uh conditions
of service and that's not acceptable to
our people
i don't know what you've been offered
which is why i asked you because um
according to some of this uh this
morning's papers you've been offered
three percent plus another one percent
if uh other guidelines are met so is it
two percent or three percent that you've
been offered as a baseline
[Music]
it's two percent we've been offered as a
baseline by both sets of companies
okay thank you for clarifying that what
would your advice be to
thank you i'm glad you clarified it i'm
just putting it to you that other people
are suggesting otherwise and you're the
man who in the know so i'm glad you
clarified that for me what's your advice
to rmt members uh on picket lines if
agency staff were going to try to get
through that picket line
well there aren't any agency staff
there's you can see behind me there's no
agency staff available
agency staff can't carry out the work of
my members they're highly skilled safety
critical workers working in engineering
railway operations signaling high-speed
trains complicated setups there are no
agency workers available that can
replace our members this is one of the
myths that grant shaps is perpetuating
because he has problems with reality i
think sometimes there are no agency
workers coming here to work today there
is a complete lockdown of the railway on
london underground and the only people
that are working are managers that have
been trained up in a couple of hours to
take this forward as it happens the
managers union is balloting from
yesterday as well because they're facing
exactly the same problems so we think
the problems on the railway are going to
escalate
as left are going to be negotiable soon
i think united are going to ballot so
the problems are getting worse and worse
and so the government has got to to deal
with that but there are no agency
workers here there's nobody crossing our
picket line
not today mr lynch but there might be
from the north of scotland i understand
i understand that mr lynch and that's
certainly the case today but you know
will it still be the case if after this
week you still get nowhere with the
negotiations the government is saying
that they are going to bring in agency
workers my question to you is i'm
guessing that your some of your members
will still stay on the picket lines what
will they do if agency workers try to
cross those picket lines
well we will picket them what do you
think we'll do we run a picket line and
we'll ask them not to go to work do you
not know how i pick it up they do anyway
i very much know how a picket line works
i'm much older than i look uh mr lynch
uh what will what will picketing involve
well you can see what picketing involves
i can't believe this line of questioning
pick it in is standing outside the
workplace to try and encourage people
who want to go to work
not to go to work
what else do you think it involves and
what if they want
well i just wondered what else it might
involve because i very well remember uh
the picket lines of the 90s where are
you going with your mr lynch
i'm asking you what your members would
do mr lynch which picket lines are you
talking about
minor strike yeah
but does it look like the minor strike
[Music]
i'm sorry if you feel the need to
ridicule me but i'm just asking you what
you expect your membership
that's what it you won't stop it
you won't stop agency workers crossing
the picket line
we will try to stop agency workers
crossing the picket line by asking them
not to go to work what is it you're
suggesting women
i'm just asking you to try to clarify
for the benefits of the british public
we're being clarified around the country
mr lynch i'm just trying to clarify
exactly what you're saying you're trying
to prepare yourself politely
i've answered the question about six
times
if there are people trying to
satisfaction somehow
i'm asking questions on behalf of my
viewers this morning mr lynch i'm very
sorry if you find it offensive well you
seem to have gotten lost in you
no i haven't i well perhaps i could just
ask it just once more see how you feel
about it if agency workers want to cross
the picket lines so that people can go
about their work and their business and
travel around the country your members
will ask them not to cross if they
continue to want to cross then you will
allow them to do so yes or no
we won't allow them to do so it's up to
them whether they do so or not we will
ask them
under the laws of this land not to cross
the picket line and not to be strike
breakers but if if agency workers think
they can go into a signaling center or
operate a train
they're going to have a bit of a problem
aren't they so what do you think these
agency workers going to do when they
report and have across the picket line
they're not trained to do the uh because
it's probably illegal for them it's
probably illegal for them to attempt to
just one final question before i let you
go because i think you've got a very
busy day you've got a very busy day
ahead of you so let me just ask you one
final question if the three strikes of
this week do not amount to a 7.1 percent
pay rise offer being offered to your
members
uh will you go on strike again
yes we will go on strike again if we
don't get a settlement to the issues so
after this phase of action we will
review the situation we'll look at where
the negotiating position is we'll
continue to talk to the companies
every opportunity and if we need to take
into further industrial action that's
what we'll do
it's an absolute pleasure to talk to you
mr lynch this morning thank you so much
for joining us and hopefully we can chat
in person sometime very soon thank you